but
also let's just update this one uh the
fabiano game because
the king was looking very exposed and we
just get to the current position because
it's actually getting quite exciting
knight on df5 was played
and well you can't resist playing a move
like this right i mean look at this
andre's the the london system is giving
the most interesting position today
that's what the london system does you
play the london system you're guaranteed
a very exciting sacrificial queen
sacrifice game is that you don't think
so
i mean i'm very delighted that we're
separated by several continents because
[Laughter]
yeah
there is a little bit of a conflict
boiling here um now i have to say that
you know it was actually the most
exciting uh position and i followed
earlier on and uh black seems to have
had some opportunities earlier on um to
take the lead but uh for what it is now
i love you on ig for queen secourino
it's obviously not queen sacrifice
because just pointing out you just
cannot take you cannot lose control of
this one but
it really does look like the black
king's in a lot of trouble he's played
h5 to give himself the
h7 square but now
the queen is just sneaking its way in
and well to be fair
i suppose you have to take this piece
right because otherwise you you're
losing without any extra material you
might as well take the material and pray
um
so he he tries to hold on
the bishop is so strong on on e5
queen h6 meaning the rook can't move
because a queen takes g7
and the big threat here
is what bishop takes g7 or is there
something stronger i guess just bishop
takes g7 is good enough
f7 as well is a big set yeah just taking
place oh of course just taking off
everything yeah yeah
there are
so many threads
too many frets here